BRIEFING SO BE SURE TO BE
WATCHING ON FOX AT 2:30 IN THE
AFTERNOON SO LET’S BRING IN
CONGRESSMAN BRIAN BABIN IN TEXAS
AND OF COURSE TEXAS HAS GOT THE
WORST OF IT WHEN IT COMES TO
HOW TEXAS HAS BEEN AFFECTED.
CONGRESSMAN, WHEN THE NUMBERS GO
UP IN TEXAS AT ANY POINT DOES
ANYONE EVER BRING UP THAT THE
ILLEGALS ARE COMING IN HERE,
NOT EXACTLY VACCINATED, NOT EVEN
TESTED?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU THREE.
BRIAN:  GOOD MORNING.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THAT TEXAS
HAS TAKEN THE BRUNT OF THIS ALL
BECAUSE OF THE INVITATION,
BASICALLY, THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE STARTING
BACK WHEN HE WAS A CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE HAS REVERSED THESE WONDERFUL
POLICIES THAT WORKED AND THAT
WERE DEVELOPED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP BACK DURING HIS TRIAL AT
THE BORDER AND THAT WAS BACK IN
2019, AND INCREDIBLY, WE SAW
SECRETARY OF DHS MAYORKAS THIS
WEEK, TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF
THE HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE
AND SAID THAT THE BORDER, UNDER
BIDEN, IS NO LESS SECURE THAN
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST WHOPPER I’VE
HEARD PROBABLY IN 25 YEARS
BECAUSE AS HE SAID THAT, THAT’S
WHEN THERE WERE 15,000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT WERE UNDERNEATH
THAT BRIDGE, AND THE NUMBERS,
YOU’RE RIGHT.
THEY DON’T ADD UP.
WHAT’S HAPPENING, THE LAST I
HEARD THAT THERE WERE LESS THAN
2,000 HAITIANS THAT WERE
RETURNED OR   REPATRIATEED AND
THERE’S STILL THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGALS THAT ARE
UNACCOUNTED FOR , AND IT’S A
SHELL GAME, EXACTLY WHAT THEY
DID EARLY IN THE YEAR, WHEN I
WENT DOWN TO THE DONNA FACILITY
AND SAW KIDS IN CAGES, KIDS IN
THESE CELLS, AND THEN JUST A FEW
DAYS LATER, THEY TOOK PICTURES
OF THESE KIDS THAT WERE THERE
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN THESE
CELLS ARE EMPTY.
ALL THEY DID WAS MOVE THEM
ACROSS THE STREET.
BRIAN:  YUP TO MILITARY BASES.
STEVE: AND CONGRESSMAN, YOU KNOW
, THE REASON THE
ADMINISTRATION IS STONEWALL
ING AND WHEN YOU WERE
REFERRING TO SECRETARY MAYORKAS,
HE WOULDN’T EVEN GIVE A BALLPARK
NUMBER OF HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN DEPORTED.
IT’S BECAUSE JOE BIDEN HAS GOT A
PROBLEM.
THE REPUBLICANS WANT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER STRONGER AND THE
DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT ANYBODY
DEPORTED SO IF THEY GIVE A
NUMBER THEN IT’S LIKE LOOK WHAT
JOE BIDEN IS DOING.
HE CAN’T WIN EITHER WAY, AND
ULTIMATELY WHAT’S GOING ON, WE
CAN’T WIN EITHER WAY.
>> WELL, STEVE, WE KNOW WHAT
THE GRAND STRATEGY OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY IS.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE AMERICA, A
HOPE AND CHANGE THAT STARTED
UNDER OBAMA AND NOW IT’S REALLY
GOING AT JUST RACE HORSE SPEED,
AND THEY WANT TO CHANGE AMERICA,
THEY WANT TO REPLACE THE
AMERICAN ELECTORATE WITH
THIRD WORLD IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE
COMING IN ILLEGALLY MANY OF THEM
COVID POSITIVE, DRUG RESISTANT
TUBERCULOSIS, I’M A HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER I CAN TELL YOU IT’S A
DISASTER DOWN THERE FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT, AND
THEY JUST WANT TO CHANGE THE
ELECTORATE AND PUT THESE
PEOPLE ON A PATH TO CITIZENSHIP
AND FRANCHISE THEM WITH A VOTE
AND HAVE A PERMANENT MAJORITY,
ON EVERY FACE, WE CAN SEE EVERY
ASPECT THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
TO CHANGE AMERICA FROM WHAT WE
KNOW, WHAT WE LOVE, AND WHAT WE
HAVE ENJOYED FOR 244 YEARS.
IT’S DESPICABLE.
AINSLEY: HIS APPROVAL RATING IS
TAKING A BIG HIM IF YOU LOOK
BACK IN JULY, 55% OF THE FOLKS
APPROVED BIDEN AND IN SEPTEMBER,
44%, DISAPPROVAL IN JULY IT WAS
43 AND IN SEPTEMBER IT WAS 53%.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A BIG HIT
AND WHAT IS THIS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE MID-TERMS OR  IN THREE
YEARS?
>> WELL, WE’RE LOOKING AT
PROBABLY, WE’LL HAVE 2 MILLION
COME ACROSS THIS YEAR, BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
AT THE END OF BIDEN’S
ADMINISTRATION, HIS FOUR YEARS
HE’LL HAVE 8 MILLION, 8 MILLION
ILLEGALS WILL HAVE CROSSED.
HE HAS NO INTENTION, THE
DEMOCRATS THAT HE HAS
SURROUNDED HIMSELF WITH, HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO INTENTION OF
SECURING THIS BORDER, AND SO
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS, AND I
TELL YOU, OUR GOVERNOR, GREG
ABBOTT, AND THE GREAT STATE OF
TEXAS, HAS IT WITHIN THEIR POWER
CONSTITUTIONALLY, THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION, ARTICLE 4
, SECTION 4 OF OUR CONSTITUTION
, SAYS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL GUARANTEE EACH
STATE A REPUBLICAN FORM OF
GOVERNMENT AND ALSO PROTECT US
FROM INVASION, AND THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY NOT OBEYING THE LAW.
THEY ARE PUTTING MANY MANY
PEOPLE IN DANGER, ON EVERY
ASPECT, TERRORISM, CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY, DRUGS, PUBLIC HEALTH,
YOU NAME IT, IT’S HAPPENING, AND
THE GOVERNOR NEEDS TO CONTINUE
WHAT HE’S DOING AND THAT IS
STEPPING UP WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY, WITH TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD AND THAT SECURING
THAT BORDER OURSELVES AND I’M
VERY PROUD TO SEE THAT HAPPENING
AND I WANT TO SEE IT HAPPEN A
LOT MORE, BECAUSE THAT’S THE
ONLY THING THAT’S GOING TO
SAVE THIS GREAT VIRUS.
BRIAN:  ITS GOT TO BE QUICKER.
IT’S TAKING WAY TOO LONG.
BY THE WAY, LINDSEY GRAHAM TWEET
ED OUT, THE COYOTES AND
CARTELS WILL APPRECIATE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REMOVING BORDER PATROL AGENTS ON
HORSEBACK, AS THEY’RE QUITE
EFFECTIVE.
THAT’S ANOTHER THING THEY ARE
DOING WITHOUT EVEN UNDERSTANDING
THE TERRAIN AND WHAT THEY WERE
DOING, THEY JUST BANNED IT AND
CONDEMNED IT AND THAT’S WHAT
THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE.
I’VE GOT TO ASK YOU TOO, HOW
DOES ALL THIS LEAD TO
IMPEACHMENT?
YOU’RE ONE OF THE PEOPLE SIGNING
OFF SAYING THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
BE IMPEACHED.
WHERE IS THIS GOING?
>> WELL, WITH US IN THE
MINORITY AND WITH PELOSI IN
CHARGE IN THE HOUSE, IT’S
PROBABLY NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME DEMOCRATS
TO SUCCESSFULLY IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT OR  ANYBODY THAT
HE HAS ANY OF HIS SUBORDINATES
BUT MANY OF THEM NEED TO BE
REMOVED.
I AM ON MY GOOD FRIEND BOB GIBBS
HADS FROM OHIO, HE’S GOT
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT AGAINST
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE’S THE ABSOLUTE MOST IN
COMPETENT COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
THAT WE’VE EVER SEEN.
I KNOW IN MY LIFETIME AND I’M AN
ARMY AND AIR FORCE VETERAN
MYSELF, AND THE THINGS THAT HE’S
DONE ON THE BORDER, STOPPING THE
GREAT POLICIES THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME UP WITH,
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THAT EARLIER
, LETTING THOUSANDS OF
COVID POSITIVE INDIVIDUAL
MIGRANTS COME ACROSS ILLEGALLY,
INTO OUR COUNTRY, STOPPING
UNILATERALLY STOPPING THE
FEDERAL MANDATE FOR
EVICTIONS, AGAINST THE
WARNING OF THE SUPREME COURT
AND THEN THE AFGHANISTAN DEBACLE
, HAVING LEFT AMERICANS
THERE, LEFT 85-$90 BILLION WORTH
OF ASSETS THERE, AND NOT HAVING
A PLAN TO GET AMERICAN CITIZENS
OUT OR  OUR ALLIES.
STEVE: CONGRESSMAN, BRIAN BABIN
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS,
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AINSLEY: HE’S A VETERAN, HIS SON